[Music]
don't blink but we're now just a few
crawls away from 2022. what i'd like to
give a recap of 2021 like we always do
on the channel i think that for today
it's better to take a look at what we
have in store for 2022. yes it's our
pre-year preview right here yeah we all
know you're all expecting attack on
titan or something like that so how
about having a caveat of only focusing
on new series that way i can give some
possible hidden gems their much needed
shine after realizing that my previous
videos on anticipated anime ended up
being heavy on sequels so what'd you say
about that then it's the top 10 most
anticipated anime this 2022 but before
we proceed let's thank today's sponsors
another eden fancy jrpgs back in the
late 90s to early 2000s then you
probably heard of the chrono series long
hailed as one of the best games out
there if you're wondering what the
creators are up to these days well we've
got our answer for you introducing
another eden a free-to-play rpg that's
the brainchild of two heavyweights in
the jrpg world you don't typically see
console tear storytelling in mobile
games but these guys have done it
however today's main event is the
crossover with chrono cross itself yep
you heard that right written by the man
massa delgado himself this is the
ultimate story that will connect the
best of both worlds players will be able
to relive the magic of the chrono cross
days with exclusive stories crossover
characters that don't have to be rolled
for and multiple endings the best part
about this the event isn't even time
limited the best time to start is now
and i'll help to get you started all you
need to do is follow the link in the
description box below and sit back to
enjoy a magical journey that connects
the past and the future
8th grader syndrome those words quickly
conjure up images in your mind perhaps
of a time past that you feel shame
looking back at perhaps of that one
classmate of yours that you just don't
get perhaps you're all just like sid
gargano once drowning in imaginations
and dreaming of being the mastermind
behind heroes and villains reborn as a
noble in a world of magic after a
mandatory visit from trotcon sid seeks
to put his dreams to the test having
dames and recruiting members to his
organization shadow garden he looks to
take down his imagined cult of diabolos
and their goal of resurrecting an
ancient evil unfortunately the cult of
diabolus is realer than sid would have
ever thought now here's an it's a guy
that i didn't feature before the
eminence in shadow looks to be an
interesting town that looks to combine
some elements of the faction building
formula and good old over-the-top
tunibio it may seem a little bit whack
at first but i think that it could end
up being a sleeper hit of the season
thanks to its very charismatic lead
[Music]
don't let the cover art fool you on this
one i myself got tricked into thinking
this is one of those coming-of-age
dramas and i couldn't be more wrong so
what is summertime render them what if i
told you it's a shonen jump series
that's quite darker than the usual
shonen fair and plays around with the
idea of time loops are you surprised i
mean i sure was shin bay ajiro doesn't
have what i call an extraordinary life
things change when one of the gofune
sisters he used to live with ushio dies
in a supposed drowning however upon
seeing the bruises on the body of the
sister as well as getting a vision from
ushio herself he knows that something
was amiss shifting shadows creep along
the island and it would take a
monumental strength to save everyone
with mio and others shin bay looks to
find a future where his friends and
family survive a tour task i'd say with
a happy ending seemingly slipping
further and further away against an
enemy smarter than it seems if you're
into mystery thrillers that soon end up
giving you a lot of fighting and action
you should add this to your plan to
watch list with its emphasis on time
loops and such i'm sure that fans of re
zero and edge of tomorrow will have
something to enjoy here
[Music]
past tokyo bay stands a special sector
far east special district more commonly
known as 24th ward their three childhood
friends grew up together in spite of
their differences but their relationship
changes in the wake of an incident a
year later their phones all ring
simultaneously it's a call from a
longtime friend who supposedly died and
the phone call leaves them with one
instruction choose the future reunited
under a new mission the three seek to
protect the 24th ward and all they hold
dear but will they be able to overcome
their differences and save everyone
original anime from cloverworks here we
go is it just me or does tokyo 24th ward
somehow give off our ohana vibes that or
one direct priority however this time i
can see this turning into more of an
action thriller that could be a sleeper
hit of the season january just can't
come soon enough at number seven we have
requiem of rose king
[Music]
historical drama never goes out of
flavor especially something with such a
dark and noir atmosphere like this
requiem of rose king is a series loosely
based on shakespearean works henry vi
and richard iii born a cursed noble
richard grapples against self-identity
possessing both male and female
characteristics he immediately finds
himself the object of scorn despite
being loved by his father the complete
opposite can be said of his mother
leading him to a childhood of hatred as
he grows up richard starts to believe
that he can find salvation by leading
his father to the throne however enemies
lie in weight featuring no less than
jean-dark herself with the war of roses
in full swing will richard bring his
family to glory or will he drag it down
the depths of the abyss as vanitas has
shown us so far dark fantasy will always
have its fair share of fans for those
who are into classic literature or just
enjoy dramatic shows with some
supernatural drama written all over it
then this is something worth looking out
for
i clearly remember back then people were
saying things like if you haven't read
uzumaki you haven't experienced japanese
horror yet now what i wonder if such
claims could still be justified now
almost a decade after that hype one
thing is for sure uzumaki is one of the
most notable horror manga i've ever read
and it's very due for an anime
adaptation one that we'll be getting in
the fall of 2022. the premise is simple
actually it's a story about bizarre
events involving spirals and one that as
expected slowly escalates an obsession
with the shape is but the prelude to an
entire town spiral into madness having
experienced the story in manga form i
think that one of the biggest selling
points for uzumaki is the art juji ito
is a master of horror and it clearly
shows with how disturbing and spine
chilling the illustrations are with a
relatively short story compared to the
typical manga series and a confirmed
episode count of just four uzumaki looks
to be one of those short but powerful
types of anime i'm expecting theatrical
quality that more than amplifies the
horrors that junji ito's mind is capable
of creating
[Music]
[Music]
up next we have bubble yep that's the
title bubble it's an original anime
project that's set to premiere on
netflix but first things first when was
the last time you saw an anime project
generate so much hype doing so little
well it's not blowing up the internet
viral but the moment the trailer hit
i've seen some excited chattering
related to bubble then again who can
blame them urobuchi sawano and araki all
involved that's quite the all-star
lineup you've got there bringing
together some of the people involved in
beloved anime masterpieces like attack
on titan psycho pass fate zero and more
and it's by wit to boot there is a lot
to be excited about the parkour scene
looks nothing short of awesome and it
seems that this is a movie that will
bring the feels certainly a welcome
addition to 2022's anime lineup
fourth is hell's paradise for someone
who's tired of this world all of the
killing and betrayal what greater curse
could there be than immortality betrayed
ninja gabimaru the hollow thought he'd
accepted his fate yet death refuses to
take a hold of him owning to his
subconscious desire to live and return
to his wife in exchange executioner
assimon comes to the ninja with a
proposal to gain pardon he's to join an
expedition to an island south of japan
the mythical elixir of life is said to
be on the island and it's the key to the
ninja's freedom however dangers far
greater than any man have seen lurk on
that island will gabimaru and his ragtag
crew of criminals survive and grasp
freedom the premise is quite interesting
and i found myself picking the manga up
and reading quite a bit of it what i
like the most about this story is that
it's not just a simple good and evil
type of action story it goes beyond that
with characters that may not be as bad
as their reputation say come in for the
action and adventure get amazed by the
good characterization sums up my
experience reading it so i can't wait to
see it get animated
in third place we have blue lock
second
it's about time we've got another one of
those gritty sports anime and blue locks
there to fill that void the titular blue
locks a prison-like facility built with
a sole purpose to find japan's next
national team strike up from a pool of
hundreds of participants only one will
get chosen and the rest get banned from
joining the team forever one of the
prospects is yoichi a striker dealing
with doubts further pushed by an
unselfish play costing his team the
nationals seeing the blue lock project
as an opportunity to clear his mind he
enters the facility with the goal of
grabbing hold of glory as the start of
the national team blue lock takes the
friendship and teamwork themes of
typical sports anime and turns those
conventions upside down oh and their
superpowers too reality just doesn't
work that way so the series instead
delves on a more cynical take going with
the themes of ego and selfishness
certainly a different take from what we
used to see and when i don't
automatically equate cynical and dark to
good the series has a lot to keep you
entertained the characters end up being
interesting and hard to predict and it's
up to you to decide how you look at them
considering their circumstances you
rarely see psychological and sports
combine as a genre but if you want to
see one done beautifully then blue lock
is your pick
our second most anticipated anime this
2022 is spy family
[Music]
how could i have forgotten about this
before even before it became an anime
spy family is a perennial favorite i've
seen a lot of people talk about it so
imagine the collective shouts of joy
when an anime was finally announced for
the sake of world peace there's no
hurdle twilight won't take however that
statement just had to be put to the test
with his latest assignment you see to
investigate the politician donovan
desmond he gets tasked with infiltrating
said sun school but how does one do that
easy get married have a child and play
family twilight now taking the alias
lloyd forger quickly adapts his family
but it turns out that the rest of his
adapted family have their own hidden
natures a secret agent an assassin and a
kid who can read minds what happens when
they come together working towards their
agendas while pretending to be an
ordinary loving family now this is a
comedy i can get behind i love how it
intertwines action with comedy thanks to
the absurd setup and scenarios that can
quickly turn into thrilling sequences if
you enjoy those mystery and mrs smith
type stories this could be the anime for
you it's also got a slew of wholesome
and relatable moments for an adult man
like me so that's always a bonus
coming out on top is chainsaw man
now was this a surprise everyone just
can't get enough of chainsaw man and its
announcement is probably one of the
major events this past few months people
went wild for this upcoming show and as
early as now i'm calling this the
mainstream hit of its season now for the
uninitiated here's what it's all about
chainsaw man stars denji having outlived
his usefulness he finds himself betrayed
and slain by the same devils who are in
cahoots with the yakuza fusing with his
pet devil he gets reincarnated as the
titular chainsaw man swearing revenge on
those who betrayed him he joins the
public safety bureau as one of the
hunters bloody brutal chaotic that sums
up chainsaw man it's also extremely dark
in comparison to most shonen jump titles
and it'll surely be a great addition to
its list of more cynical series like
death note and the mentioned summertime
render however talking about it just
doesn't do it justice so make sure that
you watch it when it comes out
[Music]
so how about you what's your most
anticipated new anime of 2022 tell
everyone in the comment section down
below and share your thoughts now if you
enjoyed watching this video please head
over to my channel and see what else i
have to offer i make these countdown
videos quite often so you'll definitely
have a lot to see you might also want to
support me through either memberships or
patreon and i'll leave a link down in
the description box for you for those
don't forget to check out our sponsors
game another eden the links in the
description i hope you had fun watching
this video and i wish you a fantastic
2022 see you next time
[Music]
you